[Music]
all right
hello everybody my name is james
goldmeyer i'm a senior product manager
with horizon discovery
what we're going to talk about today is
some of our new
synthetic single guide reagents and with
a particular focus on
screening applications as well as some
work in some very complex
cell types so what we're going to do
today
is start with just a very brief overview
of the crispr cast 9 system
to to really orientate you know
everybody to to what we're going to talk
about the rest of the
the event we're going to go through some
considerations around
reagent design and selection of you know
picking the right format for the
experiment in mind
then we'll talk about how we
specifically
designed our algorithm for
guide rnas for functionality and
specificity
obviously with the intent of of
maximizing your experimental success
and then we'll go through and talk about
functional knockout
using our editor synthetic guide rnas
and some of the criteria around the the
work involved there
and considerations for delivery and
analysis
um as well as you know some reagent
comparison and contrast to
to really help you figure out what the
right tools are for for the work you
want to do
okay so very quickly let's review the
crispr cast 9 system
the crispr cas9 system is really a
mechanism of adaptive immunity in
bacteria and archaic to defend against
born genetic material
it involves a couple of of major
elements
where we have the crit
where we have a crispr rna which
consists of a proto spacer as well as a
repeat region that is processed
to form the crispr rna
that's really the piece that targets uh
a foreign piece of dna and
also helps identify self from non-self
within the
within the organism but that crispr rna
will bind to another rna molecule called
tracer rna
and we wind up with this hybrid
structure of the crispr bound to the
tracer
primarily at you know where they bind is
is at that repeat
section and so we have the
um spacer derived sequence as well as
the
the repeat derived sequence the repeat
is
bound to the tracer and we wind up with
that tracer rna
crispr rna hybrid being loaded into a
cas9
which is an endonuclease the cas9 is
then targeted with the
crispr tracer complex to the appropriate
place in the genome
and creates a double-stranded break in
in that
piece of dna and the result of course is
you know
if it's something like a piece of
foreign dna invading
um a bacteria that for dna is probably
a virus or a trend or
some sort of other you know for material
and
it's not able to repair itself so when
that piece of dna gets cleaved it's
degraded
and the bacteria isn't able to to
continue
on um and survive that that particular
assault
in terms of how we've leveraged that for
um genome editing you know mammalian
cells and
are obviously able to repair their dna
and so what we do is we create that cut
that has been
repaired albeit in incorrectly
and we result in a a shift in a mutation
in the genomic dna that results in
ablation of a particular gene function
so when we think about you know how we
want to do this i think everyone's
pretty familiar with with crispr cast 9
but there's a lot of options available
for
how you might want to run your
experiment so we're quickly going to
talk about
uh some of the considerations for
reagent selection
the first really important piece is what
is your application going to be
is it something like cell line
generation are you trying to create a
particular model
cell line that you're going to do future
work in are you looking at gene function
analysis
or are you going up to something
significantly more complex such as
screening applications
where you're going to study large
complex biologies all at once
what type of cell will the experiment be
be performed in
are we considering primary versus
immortalized
cell lines which begs questions around
suitability of delivery as well as scope
of the experiment in order to get enough
cells to complete it
are the cells transfectable or
transducerable would speak to using
synthetic reagents or lentiviral
reagents
and of course our clonal cell population
is needed for for future work which goes
into the
the amount of work necessarily to create
the cell line you want to start with
the other part is there's many potential
sources of
the cas9 and the guide rna we can look
at
dna free versus expressed formats as
well as plasmid versus lymph viral
formats for a lot of the reagents
so to put that another way let's look at
this visually
a typical workflow might look something
like this image
where what we have are we have our our
cell population
we're going to introduce the cas9 and
the guide rna
we're going to select for
those cells or perhaps screen in them
and we're going to run an assay on the
end to look for
what were the results we were looking
for as an example of particularly
setting up
a cell in isolation we're probably going
to do a lot of sequencing
and colony expansion in order to get to
that particular line
but what about making the choices
it really starts with you know first of
all is the cast nine
how are we going to start with the cas9
cast 9 is not expressed in mammalian
cells
as a as a native protein so we have to
deliver it
the options there are really a
lentiviral approach
a plasmid approach delivery of purified
protein
or delivery of the cas9 mrna all of
these are viable options depending on
what the work is you're trying to do and
the amenability of the cells to the
particular format
we also have to look at what are the
types of guide rnas we want to deliver
do we want to deliver a synthetic crispr
tracer
which really is the most similar to the
native format that we talked about a few
slides ago
do we want to use a synthetic single
guide which is
a hybrid model of the crispr rna and the
tracer rna where they're fused together
do we want to use lentiviral expression
or again
plasmid expression in order to figure
out the right way to
to go through this process now what you
can see is there's lots of different
possibilities
just on this slide alone we're presented
with 16 possible combinations
and there's obviously a few more where
we might look at
all-in-one vectors or other formats
but it opens up a lot of opportunities
for making choice
now where that comes down to are what
are the applications that we might
consider
when we consider something like a
synthetic guide rna
the synthetic guide rna is going to be
delivered to the cell it's going to
create the edit
the edit is going to be propagated but
then the guide rna itself
is going to degrade so we might think
about that as an area
of d where we need dna free systems so
we might look at
clonal cell line generation arrayed
screening
or simply cells that are really easy to
transfect where we can deliver in high
abundance
other aspects to consider might be an
express format
with expressed formats we're going to
use typically a lentiviral vector
and that might be a vector where we have
either just the guide rna
with a selection marker or a lengthy
viral vector that's an all-in-one which
you can see at
the on the right-hand side at the top is
the slightly larger vector
now when we're dealing with an expressed
guide rna
we have to worry about our requirement
for enrichment because we want to
deliver
at very low multiplicities of infection
so then we want to be able to select
those cells that were
delivered and primarily this is a pool
screening approach
or for cells that are simply not
amenable to transfection
we have to use the lymphoviral approach
in order to get into the cell
so that's where we might consider all of
the the different formats
now one of the really interesting things
about guide rnas
is unlike some other biologies
good guide rna designs are typically
always good regardless of the format we
might put them in
so we don't have to worry about too much
in terms of
differences in functionality of a
synthetic approach versus a lymphe viral
approach
it's really about getting the guide in
and a good design will be will have
positive effect and a bad design will
typically
not work regardless of the format but
there is some subtlety and that's really
where
we'll get to in a little bit okay
so what are the really going to talk
about the considerations
you know one of the considerations is in
the biggest one is
obviously the design of the guide as i
just said
bad designs are are not going to work
well
at all now things that we we've learned
are that most guide rnas will create a
double-stranded break
and create an endel but not necessarily
with the same efficiency and that indel
that that gets formed
may not cause a functional knockout of
the protein that is we may not get a
frame shift in the in the area we need
that results in mistranslation
downstream
or results in a stop codon in a
truncated function
and depending on where that that cut
occurs it may occur at a point where
it's after functional domains that are
of importance and therefore
we don't get that knockout the other
piece is obviously
off target effects you know we don't
want to edit
unintended targets with with the guide
rna that creates breaks elsewhere in the
genome
that make that will confound
the data we get when we're looking at
how
how well is this phenotype able to be
recapitulated
with further work so this is where we
get into
how we've gone around deciding designing
our editor algorithm for not for crispr
knockout
it really came came down to looking at
two very
critical components the first is
obviously functionality
algorithm should select for functional
knockout
not just indel formation not simply
cutting or creating indels but it has to
create that functional knockout
which means that the protein is not
working the other half of that the
equation
is specificity we need to make sure that
we're accurate
and eliminate potential off-target sites
which would result
in biology that we're not able to fully
understand
so the way we did this was we started
with a functional assay for the
algorithm development
we functional gene knockout was detected
using a
phenotypic assay for proteasome function
with a gfp readout which is to say that
the expression of gfp was directly tied
to
knockout a decrease
in gene expression would result
in an increase sorry a decrease in
in gene expression would result in an
increase in gfp expression
and i'll talk more about that that essay
here in a little bit but really it was
an essay around
uh proteasome function and so what we
did and you can read lots more about
this
on our website was we selected 10 genes
that were involved in proteasome
function
and went and designed every possible
crispr rna so that synthetic 40 tumor to
those 10 genes it worked out to be about
1100 crispr rnas
and we delivered each and every one of
them into the particular cell line that
we were running
and what we wanted to do was look for
editing efficiency
you know where were the the guides that
were giving us
good efficiency as well as very strong
phenotypic readout
by the gfp so we looked at both the
primary readout was the gfp fluorescence
but then we went back and looked at
indel formation and other
characteristics as well
to confirm what we were seeing was
indeed true
and of course at the time we also
compared this to sirna
as a control because that experiment had
been published
and we knew what the results should look
like
so the way the development worked was
we went through and we created the 1100
crispr rnas
we delivered all of them tested all of
them
looked at um assessment and
quantification of functionality
so we looked at that phenotypic reporter
we analyzed the characteristics
for good and poor design so we were
looking for
you know the usual things gc content
motifs patterns
um you know strand preference etc and
then we went through
and selected designs
that made some sense retrained the
algorithm and continued to iterate in
other functional assays to make sure
that what we were seeing was
a more universal effect rather than an
assay specific effect
so it really was just a number of
iterations on this process
the the types of of information we
learned
are hopefully not overly surprising
but you know really what we came away
with was that functionality is position
and sequence dependent you know what we
see
are examples such as early acts on
targets could be highly functional
or non-functional if we look on the
panel on the right
what you can see at the top are two
purple arrows
pointed at uh two spots in blue
meaning they're in the first they're
actually an exon two
and what we can see is that those are
two guide rnas that are
fairly adjacent to each other they're in
the same exon they're not too far apart
and one of them is highly functional and
the next one
not so it's not just about being in
that exon and indeed we can see that
pattern repeated throughout the
other exons and throughout the other
genes so
it's not just about position
there's other factors we have to worry
about the cut site with it location
within the gene
sequence composition the sequence around
the pam gc content and strand preference
are all criteria that
really were required in order for us to
develop good functional guides
and these were all aspects that have
gone into that
but there's more to the equation what
about specificity
specificity is critically important to
the success of the experiment because we
do not want off targets
because otherwise we run the risk of
unintended effects in our experiment
so some things that we looked at and
we'll talk more about this
in a second are we we've discovered that
there was a tolerance for flaws that
varies along the guide rna so when we
look at the
example when we look at the the
stylization of
the dna on the right with the pam
sequence
what we can see are that mismatches
bulges etc with right near the seed
region which is those
first few bases right by the pam site
are not well tolerated which means that
those bases are are critical for
specificity
we need very tight matches there in
order to ensure that the guide rna will
bind successfully and cleave at that
site
however as you move farther away
there is an increasing tolerance for
mismatches
which says that it doesn't have to be a
perfectly aligned sequence
but that as we get farther away from the
pam sequence
we have a tolerance for for mismatches
and thus we had to look at that a little
deeper so we had to look at some aspects
around
scoring the specificity and looking at
that so
what we did was we built a second part
of the
design criteria that was an algorithm
specifically around
specificity and an alignment tool
and so it looked at all possible off
targets of the sequence
and it weighed the probability of each
imperfect alignment in causing
off-target cleavage
based on that position and then it
assigned a specificity score based on
all the criteria
now one of the pieces of this that was
incredibly interesting and we published
a paper on this that
we're happy to share is that the
alignment tool
didn't look just at the guide rna
against the dna we also reversed it and
looked at how does the dna respond
to the guide rna because dna can flex as
well
and we might create a bulge or a gap or
a mismatch in the dna
so it wasn't just a unidirectional
examination we looked at both sides and
so we
what what that gave us was a much more
more rigorous identification of
potential off targets
and we were able to identify potential
loss targets that a lot of other tools
are
will tend to miss because they're only
looking at the equation from one side
so what this means is that we get much
higher specificity out of the reagents
relative to to a lot of others okay
so now let's talk about the development
of the synthetic single guides
the the algorithm that we use is
used by all of the the different
knockout tools
we we run so all of the synthetic
crispers the
the single guides the lengthy virals
what's important to note is it is it
grows and evolves you know as new
information comes out we adjust it and
we look at
you know what are other design criteria
um and the criteria that went into our
our single guides are really the most
updated version so what does that look
like
what is the synthetic single guide uh
for crispr
uh cast 9 gene editing the
two-part system the crispr tracer system
is really the format that is most
analogous to what's present
in bacteria this is the system that most
matches that very early slide
talking about how the the
formative formative bacteria use it
and what it consists of is it consists
of that crispr rna that's 42 nucleotides
long
in case of the reagents that we create
for for our editor
uh designs they're modified on the five
prime end
uh with two prime ometh methyl and
phospho
thyroid bonds so you can see that
stylized in the diagram on the left side
those two red asterisks represent those
two modifications
there's also a tracer rna
that's a separate rna oligo that's 74
nucleotides long
that again is required for that
binding and loading into the guide rna
and effective targeting
and again that was modified on the three
prime end
with the tube modific with the two primo
methyl and phosphothyrate
bonds such that we get a much more
stable molecule
in the cell when we look at the
synthetic single guide
what you can see on the right is that
that's really a fusion
of the synthetic tracer and crispr
of the synthetic single guide is 100
nucleotides long
and it contains that hairpin sequence
that that creates the the overall
structure
it's got a 20 nucleotide targeting
sequence and an
80 nucleotide constant region that
really represents the rest of the
structure
around the actual targeting sequence and
it's modified at the
five prime and three prime end again
with two prime all methyl and
phosphorous thio8 bonds
so again it's it's designed for high
functionality and specificity
and being able to last within the cell
to generate the effect thanks to those
modifications
now how do we select the modification
pattern
this becomes you know part of the
importance of the function
of making sure that we're able to create
molecules that are
going to perform well and not have any
deleterious effects in the cell so
we started with some experiments it's a
older piece of publication
from 2017 where we looked at the
modification pattern
and we looked at a lot of different
modification patterns
including no modifications all the way
up to
three fold modifications at both ends
and we looked at this with both
synthetic crisper tracers as well as
single guides
now one of the pieces that's important
to note is
we can see some general trends in effect
you you'll notice at the top left of
this looking at cyclophill and b
that from 1x to 2x you know one
modification at each end to two
modifications at each end we see a
pretty big jump
in function and indeed with from 2x to
3x in this we see another
not insubstantial jump in the other
genes we looked at
psmd11 and psnb7 we see the same trend
but not to the extent and indeed in
these cases we see that the 2x
is actually the better performer
when we look at the single guides we see
the same
pattern the minimal two primal methyl
modification pattern gave us increased
stability and editing efficiency
when we delivered and so what we can see
is we can see a pattern wherein
using two modifications versus one or
three
gave us that that greatest increase
overall
in stability and editing for the
molecules
but there's there's another piece to
this we also had to look at
immune response because while we can
create molecules that are
efficient and stable if they elicit an
immune response within the cells
that creates a very significant problem
for our experiment
we obviously don't want cells to react
in a way that increases cell death
because then we can't under really
understand the biology and it confounds
things
so what we looked at was a number of
different
um modification patterns and we looked
at
several different genes all re
involved in immune response
what we were able to take away from this
was that when we looked and we looked at
the
varying levels of
immune response to the modifications as
well as cell viability which is the red
circle
on on the graph what we found was that
the
2x modification really had
a significant positive
impact on viability in that it didn't
affect it
um we we saw examples where the 1x
modification
had no effect um as well but when we
looked at the 3x modification pattern
we actually saw a couple of examples
where we saw significant decreases
in viability as well
as a as an increase in immune
gene response indicating that we're
getting cytotoxicity out of that
um triple modification pattern that's
not seen
in the other two so this is really where
where the thinking was about you know
why do we want to keep
that modification pattern to um just two
on each end rather than going to three
of the functionality was overall
about equivalent between between two and
three
and the stability is equivalent but we
did see
this slight decrease in viability with
the 3x modification pattern
that really said that 2 was was probably
going to be a better solution for
for going to work okay
so what about looking at
functions so that's how we built them
but how do we look at how
things work where this starts
is you know looking at delivery
um and can we get
efficient delivery into
orderlized cell lines so what we wanted
to look at was
you know could we generate cas9 stable
thing lines um and go ahead and expand
those out
and then use those in a number of
different downstream applications
so we're looking at screening with
synthetic guide rnas
looking at comparing arrayed crispr rnas
versus the single guide non-target
control
positive controls a number of different
aspects
um and one of the things that's also
important
in some of the work we'll we'll talk
about is there's going to be several
examples where we compare
um use of the crispr tracer
to the single guide what's important is
that with all of these
you know we have found that it is not
necessary to pre-anneal
the tracer and the crispr you can just
add them to the cells
and just mix them and deliver them
um and they will work just fine we don't
need to spend the extra time
uh to to get them to anneal they'll do
that naturally within the solution
so what's going ahead is is look at you
know
different delivery mechanisms as well as
looking at
different assay endpoints um
and so this was you know one of the
experiments we'll talk about that goes
to
you know looking at how do we screen and
why do we use the formats we use
is looking at screening examples
and looking at the types of screens that
we can run
so there's lots of different ways to do
a raid screening
and you know it's been done with several
different um
uh platforms using our our crisper
tracer mechanism
you know we've used reporter assays
where we've used a u2os ubiquitin egfp
proteosome assay precisely the you know
same assay type that we used for
some of the um early algorithm
development
there have been apoptotic enzymatic
assays
um mitotic indices assays
and then of course high content you know
imaging with
a g1s cell cycle phase reporter
lots of different examples and you can
see the three references at the bottom
where
where these different examples were used
the anderson
at l paper was the ubiquitin egfp
the kelly at al was the apoptosis as
well as the mitotic index
and the strazoska paper was the g1s
reporter line and we'll talk a little
bit more about that one because that's a
really interesting example
of how well um
a raid screening works with synthetic
guide rnas
is specifically looking at the synthetic
crispr rnas so
the way this this screen worked was
we started with a reporter cell line
where there's a egfp
fused to another moiety
that results in localization of the gfp
at different places in the cell
throughout the cell cycle
and so as we look at cell cycle
modification
we can look at how the the cells will
change so we can differentiate
all the major aspects of the cell cycle
as well as look at at what happens when
we adjust
some of the genes involved so this was
using an arrayed synthetic crispr rna
screen
using multi-parametric high content
analysis
with a library of 169 cell cycle
regulators
and what that effectively looked like
was
going through and doing high content
analysis on this g1s reporter line
and what we're able to see when we
compare gfp
expression versus hess staining is we
can see
normal behavior at the top on the left
we can see what happens when there's a
mitotic defect
we can see g1 arrest we can even see
s-phase arrest
so we're really able to isolate with
high content imaging
the different phenotypes that are
occurring due to modulation
of the cell cycle but really it comes
down to how do the guides perform
what were we able to see so when we went
and looked
the way we ran the screen was we we ran
it with
four individual crispr rnas per gene
in an array format and we looked at
numerous different parameters
throughout the cell cycle looking at
different analyses that we were running
what's important to note are the colors
when we
when we graph this visually as you're
seeing in now this middle figure
what we can see are significant changes
from normal
as either an increase or a decrease in
blue or red
what's important to note and what makes
makes this type of clustering very
valuable
is it's very visual and so we can
quickly look
and see that the four crisprs for any of
the
the given genes involved any of these
three genes
the four crisprs are clustering and
generally creating the very same effects
albeit with with more or less robustness
depending on the exact guide sequence
so we're able to go through and and
examine that and look for
did we see very consistent results
and what do they tell us um
what we were able to then do was
identify
24 genes with different roles in cell
cycle regulation with
very high confidence so we took that
list of 169
and got it down to 24 that were that
were really the most critical
and 80 percent of those hits had three
or more crispers per gene
showing the same phenotype which is
important because that's obviously what
we're screening on
we're selecting for the phenotype and
then looking at how well do the
individual guide rnas recapitulate that
and we saw a very strong correlation
between the positive reagents
which allowed identification of even
very subtle phenotypes within the
within the genes tested so we're able to
see a tremendous amount of information
with this type of a setup
now one of the other aspects that came
out of this
is we we've been screening for a very
long time
there's a very rich history with horizon
and scrutiny
and one of the pieces of that is can you
pool reagents that is
can you have multiple guide rnas
to the same gene in the same well
delivered at the same time
and see a positive effect on the cell
because it does raise questions of what
happens when we cut in too many places
in the cell
what happens when we cut the gene too
many times would that potentially be
deleterious
so what we looked at was we took the the
data from
the individuals and we compared it to
pools of four crispr oranges
again same genes same assay same format
and what we were able to come away with
was that the the phenotype
of the crispr rna pool was as good or
better than the best individual crispr
result
we also found that they can be run at
the same concentration
and that there is no impact on viability
in a non-specific manner
so what that means is that using a
pooled synthetic reagent gives us
um a equivalent
targeting at the best individuals it's
more consistent
and we're able to use a significantly
smaller amount of material because we're
condensing the footprint in the number
of wells needed in array screens
so overall it provides a tremendous
amount of tangible benefit
to the screening space okay
so given all of that why would we
develop
synthetic single guides why would we we
look to do that
well it's a simpler system synthetic
singular
single guides are obviously one ago
whereas the two-part crispr tracer is
two different all of those so we can
simplify
transfection by reducing reagents we can
simplify
library handling by reducing a liquid
handling step
and there's also been some discussion
that synthetic single guides
are more efficient than a two-part
system in certain cell types
and so we wanted to really compare this
so we did a direct comparison the
performance of synthetic signal guides
to synthetic crispr tracers
across different cell types different
delivery methods
different phenotypic assays as well as
multiple
anal analysis methodologies so we really
wanted to put these through the ringer
and make sure that we were able to see
good
consistent data to allow us to make
conclusions about when to use one versus
the other
okay so the first part of any experiment
is obviously
optimization and in order
to get good efficiency we have to
optimize delivery conditions
so what we can see here in this example
are a comparison of editing efficiency
in the bars for cyclophyll and b
using crispr tracer compared to
single guide rna in purple so we have
the crispr tracer in blue and single
guide rna and purple
as well as cell viability
in the circles above the the bar charts
what we're looking at are two different
seating conditions
of either 2500 cells per well or 10 000
cells per well
in a cancer line in an immortal cell
line
and delivery of a
dharma effect as a delivery reagent at
you know four microliters per well
varying
the amount of overall reagent used
what we can see is that there's a very
wide range of
useful transfection conditions um we are
we can see a very good consistency in
functionality of the synthetic guide rna
across a very broad range we do start to
see some differences in viability as
a lipid amount has increased which is
not unexpected
now what's also important is that there
are
different optimal conditions for both
the crispr and the tracer
in the uh sorry the crisper and and the
single guide
in the cells we can see that you know on
the left hand side
that using a very low lipid amount of
0.04 is
about where viability begins to decrease
slightly for the single guide
and then starts to drop off fairly
quickly thereafter
um and 0.15 is about where it drops at
the 10k
cell density um but what's important is
that there are conditions
where the reagents work but the takeaway
message is that it may not necessarily
be the exact same conditions for each
reagent
so that tells us part of it part
is what about changing the guide rna
dose
there is a dose dependence on editing
efficiency
which is exactly what we would expect
with with good designs we should see a
dose dependence
as as we move through and that's exactly
what we see here so again now at
different those two same two cell
densities twenty five hundred and ten
thousand
holding the amount of dharma effect
steady
at um the the
optimal condition and now
varying the guide rna dose either the
crispr tracer dose or the guide rna dose
we can see that again there are optimal
conditions for delivery of
the crisper tracer and the single guide
and
they don't necessarily overlap exactly
we do see again a viability effect of
finding a point where we get maximum
knockout while having minimum impact on
viability
um they're able to go through and select
just the right reagents so again the the
message here is that
um the single guides and the crispers
will function equally well
but they do have different optimization
conditions and we and it really is
important to find the right condition
for the reagent you're going to use
now then we wanted to test all of this
with
um functional assessment
so we we've worked out the delivery and
this is looking in
a u2 os line where this this particular
cell line is
expressing task 9 stably and
what we wanted to look at was what
happens
in the phenotype when we knock out
certain genes and so we knocked out
cbc20 and plk1
and what we were able to do is on the
left hand side with
phase microscopy with we are clearly
able to see
a an apoptotic effect on the cells and
we're seeing
reduced self proliferation and increased
apoptosis upon knockout of those
essential genes
on the right hand side seeing the
quantification of that
so we have the visual image as well as
the quantified data
and what we can see with the different
genes are
looking at individual guide rnas
one two and three the guide rna designs
are the same whether it's the single
guide or a crispr rna
looking at the pool we're able to see
again that
the effect of the pool is behaving as
good or slightly better as the best
individual
and we're able to to assess this with
comparison of proper controls
so what we can see on the right hand
side of these charts are the three
controls that were used where we have
untreated cells in the far right and
then we have
a non-targeting control guide
for comparison the non-target control
guide has has nowhere to bind
in the genome it's specifically designed
not to have a site
so it's really just showing delivery
effect and then we also have a
lethal guide which is a guide rna that
will shock the genome in hundreds to
thousands of
unique places and really drive that
apoptotic effect
so we're seeing a very broad window and
we're seeing
you know kind of the theoretical
maximums in terms of of
untreated versus the the lethal of
what the cell death could look like and
seeing a very nice assay window
other examples where we looked at uh the
guide rna effect
were we also wanted to look at some
examples where we did immunofluorescence
so in this case we stain the cells um
and what we did in this particular
example was we knocked out transferrin
receptor with synthetic guide rna
and looked at the results and again what
we're seeing
is the is the comparison of the crispr
tracer on the top
with the single guide on the bottom with
non-targeted control
the three individual guy designs and
then the pool
now uh transferrin receptor is localized
of a cell membrane endosomes and
lysosomes
and what we see is exactly what we
expect in the cell staining with the
with the control where we see that
the the staining is around those parts
of the cell
and relative to where the the nuclei
were stayed
now when we examined the um
performance with tide analysis uh to go
along with the the phenotypic outcome
what we see are that um that
the tide analysis shows about 90 editing
efficiency
within these cells so we're seeing very
high editing efficiency
as well as very high phenotypic output
another example of this
is looking at fused and sarcoma fuss
again in the same type of system in this
case the gene is
is localized in the nucleus so we should
see that very
strong co-localization which is what we
see on the left with non-targeting
controls
and then again as we do the the knockout
in assess the phenotype
we see very clearly that pooling of the
guide rnas gives us that mo
that more robust signal relative to the
individuals
and again when we look at the tight
analysis we're seeing
greater than 90 knockout again um
or greater than 90 editing efficiency
with the tight analysis
so we're getting that very strong
correlation of phenotype
and genotype with these reagents
okay but what about a more interesting
cell type
what about work in t cells so
this is where we wanted to look at um a
cell line where we suspect
that using a single guide might be
advantageous over synthetic crispr
tracers
now some challenges with this are that
t-cells are a bit more challenging to
handle they require very specific
culture conditions
they require activation and stimulation
they're very difficult to transfect
and so we had to go through and use an
rnp
complex to deliver everything to the
cells
and go through all of that optimization
but really the the results were were
very clean
and so what we're able to do is we did
uh co-delivery of the crispr tracer or
the guide rna with the cas9 protein
and then we analyzed gene editing both
at a phenotypic as well as a genotypic
output
and what that looked like was we used a
phenotypic output using
facts so we used fluorescence automated
cell sorting
and the way that works is we're we're
staining
a gene that has been knocked out and
looking at a change in fluorescence
so to do that we have to set the gates
right we have to determine what the
baseline is
looking at the image on the right at the
top working from left to right
starts with where those gates are
we have to start with unstained cells
uh so you know looking at you know where
is the baseline
of you know the background fluorescence
then we get to looking at uh how do we
determine that we're looking at only one
cell
and sorting the the cells on that axis
and when we put it all together we can
see that the cells
group in this lower left quadrant where
they are
not fluorescing and we know we have a
singular cell
on the bottom what we're seeing is
a knockout of cd3e in cd4 positive cells
so again we have that that wild type and
then the knockout of the crisper tracer
and because we set the gates now what we
can see
is that the non-targeting control with
cd 3e expression
is now in the upper right so we're able
to
stand for cd4 positive cells on the y on
the x
axis and bd3 e on the y and everything
goes to the upper right quadrant
when we knock out cd3e we see a shift
down into the the lower right quadrant
again cd4 expression is unchanged and
we're just seeing that shift
and what we see is a very equivalent
shift of the single guides and the
crisper tracers
which is important again we want to see
that good effect
but it's not quite all there we looked
at a lot of data
we looked at all of the individuals in a
lot of different
controls and what we see are that both
crispr tracer
and single guides are able to yield very
high levels of
functional knockout in primary human
t-cells
but we do see that the single guys you
know seem to perform
just a little bit better in terms of
looking
at um you know what is the overall
functional knockout
um where were the cell viability you
know they're
they're to some extent equivalent it's
some of its
individual designs against individual
design
but what we see is is just a bit more
consistency with the single guides and
also you know again that that lower
um handling requirement
the other thing we can look at you know
not just the functional knockout
but we look at the mean fluorescence
intensity which we would expect this to
pretty much be the opposite of the
knockout measurement
what we see is that fluorescence
intensity correlates very very closely
with the knockout assessment so we're
able to come away with the conclusion
that this is a very robust experimental
way of
looking at the guide rnas and we're able
to
very robustly modulate gene function
within the
uh t cells now
a little bit of this was looking at
other surface proteins we didn't just
look
at the 1g we look at lots of different
genes
and what we see when we compare the
best individual single guide with the
pool of three is again that very very
consistent
knockout level when we look at percent
knockout
now the one on this that jumps out a
little bit is that hla dr
gene what's important to note is that
has
a a component related to it
relative to t cell function
and so that gene actually well it looks
like a lower level of knockout
is actually doing exactly what we would
have expected that gene to do
as relates to the biology that it's it's
actually driving in the cell
so we're seeing very very consistent
results with
what we expect all the way across where
genes that are not necessarily
impacting t cell functionality the
knockout
is very high but with genes that do
impact functionality we we see a
reduction in apparent knockout
that's actually related to a reduction
in
cells and how those cells are behaving
all right as we start to wrap it up
you know where can we
um look at you know data
what we can see are
i think i just lost the recording
can you still hear us i can
okay are you not seeing the studio
anymore
um okay i am now it's back
okay give me just one second on the
screen and i i gotta
error message no worries let me just go
ahead and make an editing note and then
we can
restart uh looks like slide 47.
yep okay one second
alrighty all set just give it a few
seconds of silence and then you can pick
back up on 47.
okay
so one of the last pieces is looking at
how do we measure
editing um and in this particular slide
we looked at a number of different
uh possibilities we looked at a
phenotype t7 e1
tied analysis and next generation
sequencing to really look at what were
the range of
indels measured and would they create
um different you know would they create
a knockout how do we measure the
efficiency
what we see overwhelmingly is that
however you choose to measure it
it's going to you're going to get very
consistent results
um you know typically uh the lowest
result is going to be the t7 e1
but part of that because it also has a a
theoretical maximum
of 50 based on how it works um so what
we can actually see is that when we
um look at the results you know again
the t71 is very consistent within that
grouping
uh but yes it is it is a little lower in
overall magnitude
relative to some of the others but
they're all very consistent
in terms of of the result uh we get that
very solid correlation of
phenotype and next-gen sequencing
now the last thing to look at is um
you know how well do does phenotype
correlate with
the efficiency editing um and this was
looking at
next-gen sequencing ngs you know
relative to phenotypic knockout
and when we when we looked at that using
um
the assays that we've talked about what
we see
is a very strong correlation between
phenotype
and ngs readout we're able to see
percent knockout on the right and inhale
formation
uh by ngs on the on the x-axis
um and and that r-square value being
being very solid
indicating that good correlation
the the last piece is really around what
about the correlation between
uh crispers and single guides with the
phenotype
um again when we look at the percent
knockout
of single guides versus crisprs um
you know when we look at on the left
hand side with just
individuals what we see when we when we
draw the
the correlation line is that you know
there is some variation between the
individuals with crispr with
crisprs and single guides um you know as
we might expect
any given design is going to to have
some some variation depending on on the
cell and the format used
but importantly when we look on the
right when we look at the pooled
crispers and
pooled single guides as a comparison
what we see
are a very very strong correlation
all of these points fall fall very very
closely to the line
indicating that very strong correlation
which means that whether you want to use
a pool of three single guides or a pool
of four
crispr rnas which are the two uh pooled
reagent formats we predominantly sell
going to get very very consistent
results across all of them
okay so what can we conclude we can
conclude that
nine algorithm based synthetic guide
rnas
are compatible with a lot of different
cat9 formats
we know that synthetic crispr rnas and
synthetic single guides
show high phenotypic knockout in
multiple cell models
um we demonstrated this effect in both
cancer lines as well as
difficult primary cells fooling this
the synthetic single guides or the
synthetic guide rnas for each reagent
really gives the the overall best and
most consistent results
but it's important to know that we get
good consistent results out of the
individuals
because the way you validate a pool is
to go back and test those those
those guide rnas independently
lastly we see that
both crisprs and single guides show
similar activity
in all the systems we we tested uh and
synthetic guides show editing at a bit
lower concentration which could lead to
better functionality
in some more sensitive cellular systems
well they generally provide similar
performance
um you know to crispr tracers single
guides do
simplify the workflow ever so slightly
you know particularly in screening where
that liquid handling step is important
and and give us a better result and so
lastly just to leave you with you know
what are the products and the formats
that are available
we have individual gene um reagents
that cover the entire human and mouse
genomes both as individuals or
sets of three and then of course we have
screening libraries as well for catalog
libraries of common gene families
all the way up to the entire human
genome and those use that that pooled
format where we have the three guides
for well
three guides combined in a single well
you can also do cherry pick custom
libraries where
simply bring your gene list and we can
create a
unique library specific to and tailored
to your exact experimental needs
um and everything is available with
libraries in either 96 or 384 well
or we can also do echo compatible plates
uh upon request
in various amounts and so at that point
i will say thank you everybody for your
time
if you do have any any other questions
please email us
at technical.horizondiscovery.com
or also please note that right now the
booth is currently manned
and kids come by there and chat with one
of our specialists and we'll be happy to
talk to you about whatever comes next
so again thank you very much
okay awesome job well we're all set
pretty much from
here i'll just do some quick editing on
the front and back ends
and the quick slide redo and then have
your presentation ready for the event
next week
okay thank you
really good job james
okay yeah thanks everybody thanks tyler
for putting this together you know so
quick
of course and feel free to reach out if
you guys have any questions at all
all right thank you so much bye